[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be addressing
a question that I'm sure has crossed the
minds of many Harry Potter fans that is
why on earth is Harry left with the
Dursleys I mean sure they're related to
him but they're awful awful people
how could Harry Potter the boy who
famously survived an attack from the
Dark Lord be left with people like this
this passage from the Philosopher's
Stone describes how Harry felt about
this situation when he had been younger
Harry had dreamed and dreamed of some
unknown relation coming to take him away
but it had never happened
the desease were his only family over
the course of the books and films the
Dursleys particularly Vernon Dursley did
a lot of horrible things to Harry these
things include but are not limited to
putting bars on Harry's window in the
Chamber of Secrets
this was after Dobby got Harry in
trouble with the ministry temporarily
preventing him from performing magic for
fear of expulsion from Hogwarts shutting
Harry's owl Hedwig in a locked cage this
was to prevent Harry from having any
source of happiness while at privet
drive telling Harry that his parents the
great James and Lily Potter died in a
car crash
this one really enraged Hagrid forcing
Harry to live in a cupboard under the
stairs the house on privet drive even
had an extra bedroom that he could have
used but they kept it empty as a spare
room for Dudley this was particularly
cruel of them keeping Harry from reading
his mail and of loss of a stone Vernon
tries his very best to keep Harry from
his Hogwarts acceptance letter no matter
how many showed up at the door this
didn't stop Dumbledore however as he
ended up sending Hagrid to deliver the
message in person even better instead of
being celebrated for magic the desease
hated Harry for it they hated any and
all things that weren't normal
the junior held the belief that her
parents preferred her magical sister to
her
which forever made her despise the
entire Wizarding World
when Vernon and petunia met but she
confessed to Fernand that her sister was
a witch this led to them bonding over
her being freaked so we know they're
awful and now you've been refreshed in
some of the cruel things that Harry had
to endure so again
why was he left with them the answer to
this question once again it feels like
everything relates to this come santa
Harry's bloodline Harry's Aunt Petunia
was of course the sister of Harry's
mother Lily Potter because petunia was
Harry's blood relative people held the
belief that Lily's act of sacrificial
protection would continue on and be
transmitted through petunia when I say
the least
sacrificial protection I am of course
referring to the powerful counter charm
that Lily Potter cast on Harry when she
was being attacked by a Lord Voldemort a
sacrificial protection charm is
performed when someone sacrifices their
own life willingly and out of deep pure
love to save the life of someone else so
regardless of how they treated Harry he
was still safer with the Dursleys than
with anyone else sure he could have
lived with the Weasleys and had fresh
jumpers knitted for him by Molly every
week but he just would not have been as
safe there ultimately keeping him alive
was a top priority and that's all for
this video I hope you enjoyed it and if
you did please give the video a like if
you have any questions please put them
down in the comment section below until
next time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]
you